it's not often that Personnel changes
are worth a video but these ones are as
they look set to rearrange the
generative AI landscape I've read pretty
much every report article exclusive and
rumor out there on the firing of the CEO
of open AI Sam Alman and the resignation
of the president and co-founder Greg
Brockman I'm going to try to distill the
most interesting bits and cover angles
that I don't think others have but let's
start with this bombshell tweet from
Greg Brockman again the president and
co-founder of open aai or I should say
the former president he said that last
night Sam got a text from Ilia satova
that's the chief scientist of open Ai
and a key board member asking to talk at
noon on Friday and at this point you can
tell that either Sam Alman drafted this
bit or a third party maybe a lawyer
because it goes into the third person
Sam joined a Google meet and the whole
board except Greg himself was there ilot
told Sam he was being fired and that the
news was going out very soon but that
must have been a very short call because
at 12:19 p.m. Greg got a text from Ilia
asking for a quick call firing the
public face of your company the CEO and
co-founder samman in a 15minute no
notice Google meet call is quite a
dramatic move anyway Ilia satk and the
board were on a roll because 4 minutes
later Greg Brockman was told that he was
being removed from the board
interestingly they told him he was vital
to the company and he would retain his
role and I'll get to open AI statement
in a moment it does seem though that
literally one of the only people in the
world who had any real notice was Myra
murati the new interim CEO who found out
the night prior anyway bear in mind that
statement that Ilia SATA said that Greg
Brockman was vital to the company and
even the open AI blog post put it like
this as part of this transition Greg
Brockman will be stepping down as
chairman of the board makes it seem
voluntary and will remain in his role at
the company reporting to the CEO we now
know that Greg Brockman had other ideas
saying based on today's news the firing
of samman I quit so that's someone
supposedly vital to the company who is
no longer going to be there now at this
point the obvious question is well what
did Sam mman do to get fired it must
have been bad enough to get fired in a
no noticed 15minute Google meets call
but not so bad that Greg Brockman didn't
feel the need to resign in solidarity
well there are one or two leading
theories which I'll get to in a moment
but first what did the board say they
say that his departure follows a
deliberative review process by the board
which concluded that he was not
consistently candid or honest in his
Communications with the board and they
go on hindering its ability to exercise
its responsibilities their
responsibility which they later
reiterate is building safe AGI that
benefits all of humanity so they must
have believed that samman not being
honest hindered their ability to build
safe AGI they say the board no longer
has confidence in his ability to
continue leading open AI the natural
follow on question therefore becomes
what wasn't he honest about it must have
been something fairly dramatic that he
wasn't candid about otherwise you
wouldn't fire the CEO giving all of the
investors literally no notice and doing
it in such a way that multiple other
employees have resigned not just Greg
Brockman the information in an exclusive
put it like this jacob puki the
company's director of research Alexandra
Madre head of a team evaluating
potential risk from Ai and Simon seidor
a seven-year researcher at the startup
have told Associates that they have
resigned too the departures are a sign
of immense disappointment among some
employees and underscore long simmering
divisions at the chat gbt Creator about
AI safety practices and don't forget
those aren't just any employees Jacob py
is the gp4 lead and director of research
or he was so we have the guy responsible
for the pre-training of GPT 4 resigning
and the vital Greg Brockman resigning
too will there even be a viable open AI
after this well yes according to many
people and I'll get to that in a second
but what about Alexandra Madre well it
was just in late October about 3 weeks
ago when he was announced to be the head
of their preparedness team that's a
super important role leading the team
that will help track evaluate forecast
and protect against catastrophic risks
so it seems if this was a safety play
it's quite strange for him to resign too
something definitely doesn't add up here
it's not just the safety people versus
the accelerationists and in another
exclusive from the information
apparently there was an impromptu not
prepared All Hands meeting following the
firing IIA SATA took questions and at
least two employees asked satsa this did
the firing amount to a coup or hostile
takeover the people in the room felt the
question implied that Sova may have felt
ultman was moving too quickly to
commercialize the software and that that
was at the expense of potential safety
concerns anyway sukova replied like this
you can call it that way sua said about
the coup allegation and I can understand
why you chose this word but I disagree
with this this was the board doing its
duty to the mission of the nonprofit
which is to make sure the open aai
builds AGI that benefits all of humanity
he was then asked whether these back
room removals are a good way to govern
the most important company in the world
that's a somewhat hype claim but
nevertheless he answered I mean fair I
agree that there is not an ideal element
to it 100% so so far we have a notion of
ultman not being totally honest about
something to do with generating profits
for the company that might put a risk
safety it feels to me that Sasa doesn't
do niceties hence the 15minute firing of
of Alman and maybe he has an issue with
what he perceives to be big egos he
recently tweeted this ego is the enemy
of growth at this point I'll note that I
feel there has been some amount of
bullying of other members of the board
who made the decision to fire Alman but
really it seems pretty clear that the
driving force behind it was Ilia Sasa so
rather than blaming less experienced
board members I would direct questions
towards Ilia Sova anyway Microsoft whose
stock is down almost 2% in the wake of
this news has rushed out a statement
remember they were given literally one
minute notice of this development the
Microsoft CEO SAA nadela and CTO Kevin
Scott who were instrumental in bringing
open AI into partnership with Microsoft
expressed utmost confidence in open AI
following the unexpected news nadela who
just two weeks ago was on stage with
Alman when mman said I look forward to
building AGI together put out a fairly
cold statement he said we have a long
longterm agreement with open aai with
full access to everything we need to
deliver on our Innovation agenda we
remain committed to our partnership and
to Myra and the team remember Microsoft
has not only invested $13 billion into
open AI but promised them the most
compute in the world to create AGI they
still need open AI to do really well but
again we're left with that central
question of what did he do that was so
bad to get him fired so abruptly but yet
not too bad that plenty of his
colleagues didn't feel the need to
resign in sympathy well one very
well-connected journalist in San
Francisco Cara swisser gave us a bit
more detail as she understands it it was
a misalignment of the profit versus
nonprofit adherence at the company we've
seen hints of that already the developer
day was an issue but what about the
developer day it couldn't have been the
hype around the developer day because
Ilia SATA retweeted this post by Sam
Orman talking about the great stuff that
they have to show off to developers so
it can't have been the developer day
happening or the hype around it nor
could it have been the iterative
deployment of gp4 Turbo the latest model
Myra murati the new interim CEO said
this about iterative deployment she was
asked by Wired Magazine whether she also
believed in iterative step-by-step
deployment of models as a path toward
AGI and she said I haven't come up with
a better way than iterative deployment
that way we get Contin ous adaptation
and feedback from the real end feeding
back into the technology and it does
seem unlikely for him to be fired over
the technical implementation of devday
that's despite the fact that there have
been quite a few challenges with Dev day
open AI have had to suspend new chat GPT
plus signups for a bit and plenty of
people have been complaining not just
about the assistance API but about
things like using GPT 3.5 in production
apparently since devday there has been a
lot more downtime for GPT 3.5 but
there's a reason I highlighted this
tweet in particular yes it's from the
founder of Lexica a great creative tool
and the conclusion is dramatic there's
no point in using GPT 3.5 in production
but when I first saw this post on my
mobile quite an interesting person had
liked it it's off their likes now but
originally Andre karpathy liked this
tweet again that's the conclusion
there's no point in using GPT 3.5 in
production instead I found mistol 7B
fine tune deployed to be way cheaper and
better so maybe Dev day included some
rushed releases and the technical
challenges go deeper than we thought
having said that it does seem like open
AI are trying to bounce back with one of
their engineering managers saying this
in response to the firing he said for
those wondering what will happen next
the answer is we'll keep shipping Sam
wman and Greg Brockman weren't
micromanagers the sparkle comes from the
many Geniuses here in research product
engineering and design there's a clear
internal uniformity among these leaders
that we're here for the bigger mission
remember that's safe AGI that's
beneficial for all humanity and even one
of the co-founders of open AI vo zerber
said this it's been sad for me to see
Sam wman and Greg Brockman go I love and
respect them much despite all of these
the mission of open AI is bigger than
any of us and stays the same build safe
AGI to benefit Humanity meanwhile samman
has been meming a little bit if I start
going off on a rant the open AI board
should go after me for the full value of
my shares which don't forget are zero as
in they can't do anything to me of
course he did also describe how his day
has been like reading his own eulogy and
that he loved his time at open aai it
does seem like he loved being there as
much as he loves lowercase letters at
this point I do want to quickly bring in
an enigmatic comment that samman made
just 2 days ago I think this is like
going to be the greatest sleep forward
that we've had yet far and the greatest
Leap Forward of any of the of the big
technological revolutions we've had so
far I'm super excited uh I can't imagine
anything more exciting to work on and on
a personal note like four times now in
the history of open ey the the most
recent time was just in the last couple
of weeks I've gotten to be in the room
um when we sort of like push the front
the sort of the veil of ignorance back
and the frontier of Discovery forward
and getting to do that is like the
professional honor of a lifetime now
remember that before training GPT 4 they
trained smaller scale versions to test
capabilities that allowed them to more
accurately predict the full capabilities
of GPT 4 when he refers to the veil of
ignorance being pushed back is he
talking about the miniature version of
GPT 5 if so did he get the boards
approval for okaying the training of
that miniature model obviously at this
point we hit the end of the road for
speculation we simply don't know until
he tells his story or the board does I
imagine the board might go first because
they are under immense pressure to
explain themselves but finally what next
for the industry well the obvious
prediction which I share with Jim fan is
a rival open AI emerges it's a bit like
the last time there was a major split at
open AI that was when Dario amade and
the anthropic team split off that
eventually gave us of course Claude 2 if
they did decide to set up a rival
company I am sure it would immediately
attract billions of dollars of
Investments don't forget as the
information reports Greg Brockman didn't
formally manage any employees and
instead spent much of his time writing
software in that role he was one of the
startup's most influential figures and
had a say in everything from product
decisions to setting directions for
engineering teams he could apparently
tackle the most difficult coding
problems and was bent on optimizing the
speed and efficiency of the company's
models he would know pretty much
everything there is to know about the
training of GPT 5 also bear in mind and
I recently spoke to someone who was
offered a job at open aai Sam mman
personally interviewed basically every
employee who joined so they all have a
direct personal connection to Sam Alman
he might well be able to bring over
dozens of open aai employees and yes
some people are speculating that this
will give a head start to Google Gemini
that was a model rumored to be better
than gp4 however in the last 48 hours
not only has it been strongly hinted
that that's pushed back to 2024 4
instead of December as expected but also
expectations are being damped down the
CEO of Google said our goal with Gemini
is to put out a state-of-the-art model
as in better than gpc4 that is where
we're going to start with Gemini 1.0 but
it's only after that that they're going
to add more Innovations truly make it
multimodal bringing in features like
memory and planning but in his original
announcement those were supposed to be
part of Gemini so now the expectations
are more of a model just slightly better
than GPT for but nothing truly
revolutionary and bear in mind that
Talent flows somewhat freely in Silicon
Valley one of the leaders of the Gemini
Project who specializes in developing
models that can incorporate both text
and images joined open AI in October and
of course people talk behind the scene
so if there were some special Source in
Gemini expect it to be shared with GPT 5
so ultimately what we are left with is a
further fracturing of the industry we
might even have a new AGI lab on our
hands before the end of the year of
course let me know in the comments what
you think is going to happen I'm also
working on my own announcement but
that's a story for another day thank you
so much for watching to the end and have
a wonderful day